alright Lucy if you want this will you
please speak Wow
she doesn't want it this is Lucille
Bluth aka Lucy this is Bob Seger my
dog's name is Minnie Lucy's a lady on
the streets but like up creek and the
dog park he also likes or doesn't like
love other dogs he's more like
indifferent towards them unless he wants
to like hump them Manny is a Chihuahua
mix so I don't know what's the mixes
Lucy's favorite toys the ball
she loves chasing ball she's very fast
she's got long legs like a model he's
had this decapitated squirrel for about
five or six years that he just like he
like loves them to death we don't have
any squeaky toys in our house cuz my
husband hates that sounded them so he's
only allowed really boring plush toys
shaped like rats Lucy this is a box for
you do you want to open it so we open it
but chuck it oh yeah see are you ready
to play yeah get it I think he loves the
orange oh oh look at that yeah this is
really weird these playing with bowls
but this is how he acts when he plays
with toys it's like quiet ggressive you
miss yeah I think this is the most
responsibilities ever been to a ball
this is a really good toy for Lucy
because she loves balls she's a lady but
she loves balls
[Music]
the other one was so fun
open it yourself I'll put it yourself
we're working on it she can't do it yet
he's very shook up there okay this is
your new best friend yes it is what is
Micky herb there it's just the squeaking
sounds like the cries of the dying
animal and she loves that he is just
ripping the face of this one she wants
to rip it apart so she's got to get it
real wet wet bare is easier to rip apart
yeah
Wow you're doing a good job ribbon
ribbon what's in here ball I'm not
excited about this one it's gonna be
squeaky and annoying this is the
equivalent to buying your child the
drums Lucy
he doesn't seem as interested he doesn't
want to sit for it if you really want
something he'll actually sit down for it
Lucy ranks these balls 12 out of 10 but
mommy wants to throw them away okay Lucy
you got to start from the middle that's
where it opens oh my god gonna hit in
the box oh you have one of these he
likes it when he's got peanut butter in
it
you put treats or peanut butter in here
and this toy currently does not have
treats with peanut butter I'm gonna try
to put a treat in this and see if he'll
get down oh I hate this she's kind of
like that this is some [ __ ] usually
there's peanut butter in here I think
this one is defective I think that's
what she's thinking he's like where's
the peanut butter literally the size of
his head many this box is bigger than
you man I could fit him in the book
alright she's got it now she's into the
boxes it sounds big and fluffy this is
gonna get so spunky when you choose it
oh man just take it away if you want
this Speak okay it's kind of nice it's
like you've got a fringe cuz it's so
cool it says um ideal for gentle sewers
and Lucy and I don't think is the
gentlest I don't get this honey maybe he
gets it out of the top five Amazon dog
toys I think see her likes this one the
best I can definitely see it see her
snuggling with this at night waking me
up in the morning with it pressing
against my face carrying it up and down
the stairs he's gonna be really happy I
think best things this is Minnie's
favorite toy
I think the bull was my favorite toy but
this is definitely many sleeper alright
Lucy's favorite were these balls because
[Music]
that's why
[Music]